this is a production of Cornell
University
alright well thank you all for coming
and thank you for inviting me this is my
second trip to Cornell I gave a seminar
in port the old port department I guess
about 10-12 years ago and I can't
remember for the life of me what it was
on so hopefully it wasn't on this but
what I'd like to do today is talk about
some of our work on co2 concentrating
mechanisms and higher plants and I'll
give a bit on the c-4 evolution story
and some of the facets that we've been
doing with that and then I also want to
talk about some interesting things we've
observed that are going on in c3 plants
to give you a nice sense that they're
much more dynamic than we thought in
terms of how they manage
photorespiration and deal with the
problems it causes and in some ways take
advantage of it so with that I'll get
started and this is an old graph that Ed
Tolbert put together from some years ago
it's the bicycle diagram that shows c3
photosynthesis and photorespiration and
it's useful because it sort of gives a
highlight of the start of our problem
which is the photo respiratory the photo
respiratory challenge that plants face
so as you're all aware co2 here gets
taken up by rubisco and bound to ru vp
and carboxylation to produce two pgas
and then using energy in the form of ATP
and NADPH they're made into sugars and
some are regenerated back into ru vp to
maintain the photosynthetic carbon
reduction cycle but in atmospheres of
low co2 like we've had in recent
millennia oxygen can be taken up by
rubisco and bound to ru vp in the ru vp
oxygenation reaction and this produces
one PG and 11 pga and 12 carbon molecule
called fossil glycol it's shown there is
PG now the fossil egg like lead has no
known used to the plant if it
accumulates it's toxic so the plant has
to deal with it using energy they
metabolize it back to PGA but in the
process who's previously fixed co2 which
is a
bit of a waste and because oxygen has
taken up in co2 is given off this is
called photorespiration now
photorespiration has a strong
environmental dependency in that worm
temperatures and rising co2 influence
the rate at which it occurs if you're at
high co2 the co2 suppresses the
oxygenase reaction and photorespiration
relative to photosynthesis here is quite
low even at higher temperatures
temperature promotes photorespiration by
promoting the oxygenase over the
carboxylation reaction and if you look
at current co2 levels which are now 400
ppm but correspondingly in the
chloroplast they would be here where
these circles are as temperature rises
photorespiration can rise to quite high
levels as you see out here and if you
close the stone aids as you would do on
a hot dry condition you can have photo
respiration rates that can become
exceedingly high and potentially
exceedingly inhibitory now to deal with
this well so this just shows the result
of photorespiration on net
photosynthesis here we have temperature
going up and at current atmospheric
levels or at least a few years ago and
twenty one percent oxygen a typical c3
photosynthetic response would be this
with a big drop off at higher
temperatures but if you reduce
photorespiration by going to two percent
oxygen or high co2 then you can see the
impact of photorespiration by comparing
the differences in rates and you see
that at high temperatures this
difference between the photorespiration
free and a photorespiration inhibited c3
plant are quite large not such a problem
at low temperatures now because of this
strong inhibition it's been understood
for years that carbon concentrating
mechanisms have evolved to deal with the
problem and the carbon concentrating
mechanisms that would have evolved
typically came up in dry environments
here where much of the c3 flora has been
inhibited by the footer
spiration reaction due to the heat of a
desert arid place like this as well as
two stomata closure to save water in
these conditions which reduces co2
around the chloroplast photorespiration
is also a serious problem for much of
the c3 flora in places like the tropical
rainforest where high temperatures that
you would often encounter would lead to
substantial oxygenase activities now the
most famous of the carbon concentrating
mechanisms that have evolved is of
course c4 photosynthesis because a
number of c4 plants are important for
our food supply and collectively it
provides about a quarter of the total
terrestrial primary productivity on the
planet just a quick review c4
photosynthesis has occurred when the
reactions of the Rubisco and the c3
metabolic cycle are compartmentalized
into the bundle sheet and no longer
expressed in the mesophyll tissue and
instead in the miso Phil you've had the
upregulation of the c-4 metabolic cycle
which begins when pep carboxylase takes
pep carboxylated to a four carbon acid
oxaloacetate which is then reduced the
male ace in the most common form of c-4
that travels to the bundle sheath where
a decarboxylated enzyme nad may lack
enzyme acts upon it to release co2
produce NADPH and then also create a
three carbon residue pyruvate that has
to go back and with energy be refloated
to pep so with each turn of this cycle
co2 gets pumped into this bundle sheath
where rubisco is localized raising co2
to levels that suppress photorespiration
now a key thing I just want to emphasize
here is that energy is required to drive
this cycle so we can think of this as an
actively driven energy-dependent carbon
concentrating mechanism to other well
known carbon concentrating mechanisms or
cam photosynthesis which you see here
which is basically the c-4 type system
only instead of spatially separated
between
miza fillin bundle sheath it's
temporarily separated between day and
night at night the stow mates open co2
comes in is carboxylated by Pepsi 20 AAA
which is reduced to male 8 that's stored
in the vacuole during the day the stow
mates clothes creating a diffusive
barrier the male 8 is released
decarboxylated releasing co2 which
builds up to suppress photorespiration
at the Rubisco site in a different group
the algae mini algae of all a wide
variety of forms you've had the
evolution of a bicarbonate pump
typically where an ATP ace pumps protons
out and in a code transport mechanism
they bring by carbonate in and then in a
specialized compartment in the
chloroplast called the paranoid in
eukaryotes in the carboxy some in
prokaryotes carbonic anhydrase converts
the bike ramen 82 co2 which then builds
up to high concentrations for round
rubisco and suppressed photorespiration
now again I want to just emphasize ATP
is needed here so this bicarbonate pump
is an actively driven CCM and then in
the rebuilding of the carbohydrate pool
that will provide the pep at night ATP
is needed so the cam system can be
considered an active pump so and in
these active co2 concentrating
mechanisms you need the energy to
concentrate the co2 the Rubisco is
localized to a co2 and reached enriched
region and you have a resistive barrier
to slow the e flex of co2 and the sea
for the resistive barrier is the bundle
sheath wall and the cam it's the whole
epidermis with closed Oh mates and then
in the algae it's a combination of a
water layer and the paranoid or carboxy
zone boundary so again there's the
examples of these active systems and
as you probably would as I mentioned
raising the co2 through this pumping
mechanism reduces photorespiration it
doesn't get rid of it but it reduces it
down to a few percentage points of
photosynthesis a second key thing of
these CCMS is that by raising co2 up to
these high levels they overcome a such a
sub States substrate saturation of
Rubisco that's present in the current
environment so here we have the
carboxylation capacity corrected for
photorespiration here we would say have
a curve at 30 degrees this is just the
Rubisco substrate response to co2 here's
the current co2 level which you can see
is this substantial substrate limitation
and then if you raise the co2 level to
what you have in a c4 or a pie renewed
then you begin to approach co2
saturation so in a low co2 environment
this is a substantial benefit that
plants would have with active CCMS now
there's a lot of interest these days and
how when and why active CCMS of the
vault and with c4 we've been working on
this a bit in the last 15 years I got on
to this when I edited a book c4 plant
biology in the late 1990s and a nice
thing about editing books is you find
out how well the field is really
understood and with respect to c4 i
found out that when it came to
evolutionary questions things were
pretty rudimentary so sort of a state of
the art at that time we thought there
were 25 independent lineages we knew
they all occurred in advanced
angiosperms there was speculation that
c4 is maybe 10 million years old the
phylogenetic understanding was pretty
poor and we knew there were a number of
species that had traits that were
intermediate between full c4 and full c3
type species
this phylogeny that Toby Kellogg
published in the book and her chapter
sort of summarizes it here we have a
phylogeny of the Carol PhillyD a class
cariño phila day and if we just look at
amaranthus here which is a group known
to have some c4 species you can see that
it's not well distinguished from other
groups species within the amaranth iseki
no podia the Alliance we didn't know
whether there were see three species
here because it hadn't been fully
surveyed and we didn't know whether
there were sister groups that might have
intermediacy and this would be true of
most of the clades where we could find
see four species be an abundant and so
we really couldn't address evolutionary
issues because of the rudimentary state
of the pile of genetics due to low
species coverage due to an inability to
know who we're c3 and who were c4 and
then also poor resolution so beginning
spurred on by this from the editing job
I did on that book my co-workers than I
here's Tammy sage one of my co-workers
we went to various orb area around the
world q new york botanical gardens
missouri botanical gardens and we went
to the air bit this herbarium specimens
in these clades where we knew c4
occurred took little pieces of samples
and measured the carbon isotope ratios
which are easily distinguished between
c3 and c4 so c4s have a carbon isotope
ratio of minus 8 2 minus 16 c 3 s or
minus 22-30 to easily determined with
the mass spec at about five dollars an
assay so we could do thousands of assays
and so we did thousands of assays on
many plant groups and then we teamed up
with Philo genus from around the world
working on these groups Thomas borscht
for example with the amaranth EC and we
were able to get them to get provide
more detailed analytical phylogenetic
assessments of the groups we were
interested in and then we mapped c3 and
c4 on to these phylogenies and so here's
just the amaranth
Stacy and by doing this having a more
detailed phylogeny because we have
something to bring to the table which is
the isotopes we then mapped it on and in
the amaranth AC you can see cleanly
there's five distinct origins of c-4 in
amaranthus in irva small one and he
tossed romia a smallish one in alternate
thera and then a relatively large one in
what we call the Golf R annoyed a five
genera group gomphrena and its allies
and now we could go and to these branch
points and ask what's going on here duh
do we have intermediate species and can
we put that intermediacy in a
phylogenetic context okay here's one
that we just published last year on the
group Belarus we have a c3 ancestral
clade that's in a sister position to a
c4 clay and we have this intermediate
clade branching here that through a
preliminary survey of crayons type
anatomy and the leaves looks to have a
lot of intermediate States and so now in
six weeks I'm going to South Africa with
my PhD student we're going to collect a
bunch of these guys so that we can
develop a living evolutionary model of
c4 now between our efforts and efforts
of others in the field we've been able
to come up with a pretty good map of c-4
evolution in the in the higher plants
and as you see here there's a cluster in
the grasses the sedges and grasses are
collectively the grama noids there's a
cluster in the carry a fillet Lee's
order and then there's a number of
scattered groups of varying sizes in the
angiosperms and when we go and look
carefully we can identify over 60
independent lineages of c-4 evolution
which is kind of surprising given that
it's a fairly complex trait
now with this ability to use the
phylogeny so we can also go and use a
molecular clock approach to estimate
when c4 evolved in these distinct
lineages and my colleague Pascal
Christian did this in a paper that he
published for grasses in 2008 and then
we published for grasses and eudicots in
2011 which is summarized in my annual
review here and this shows that spread
between the stem node and the crown node
with the midpoint there for 46 lineages
of grasses and eudicots and you see that
beginning about 30 million years ago
based on molecular clock approaches the
c-4 lineages diverged from ancestral see
three lineages and as you come forward
in time over the past 50 million years
you get more and more lineages appearing
now we can link this up with changes in
Earth's climate and atmosphere so if we
look at atmospheric co2 content shown
here this beginning here correlates with
a drop in atmospheric co2 down towards
levels similar to today and consistently
geological studies have shown c4
isotopes and fossils and then evidence a
big expansion of c-4 grasslands and
other ecosystems in the subsequent 20 to
30 million year period now recently what
I wanted to do is look at this in a
little more detail and on the next graph
so I'm going to show you response is
related to the midpoint between stem and
crown nodes in these projected dates so
what I did is I went and was able to
estimate the number of species for each
of the projected c4 lineages and now we
can estimate the time origins for 52
lineages which are shown here and what
you can see is that using the midpoint
just to keep the graph kind of clean
here's the range between crown and stem
notes
for the 52 of the 60 lineages you can
see that the older lineages are the ones
that have become the most species with
three grass lineages corridos andropogon
a and the Melinda group being the most
species the eudicots which tend to be
about as old as the grasses the older
ones are more species and as you come
down to the younger group such a you
find that in grasses and the red
triangles eudicots in the black circles
and sedges in the blue symbols in the
last five to ten million years all the
groups are fairly small in terms of
species number and then we can look at
when these lineages occur just the
number of lineages as a function of the
last 30 million years starting here 20
to 30 million years ago and then a burst
of evolutionary diversification in the
last 15 million years now this is a
recent co2 graph with oxygen isotope
data that gives a climate proxy I'll
just focus on co2 this is a paper at a
mark the ghani's group that Yale that
used a number of proxies to estimate co2
levels over the last 40 million years
here we are today 40 million years ago
and at the time 42 30 million years ago
co2 levels are projected to be high by a
number of complementary proxies and then
in the late oligocene about 25 million
years ago the co2 level drops down a
little bit of a drop here and then over
the last 15 million years it's been
about what it was in recent geological
time with a drop down to below 300 ppm
in the last ice age now putting on this
graph from the previous panel i showed
you to just allow you to look at co2
versus see for evolutionary
diversification you see in these higher
co2 periods a few groups diverged and
then in the low co2 periods
the last 20 million years is when most
of them diverged and then if you look
right after this little drop from about
500 to somewhere around 400 ppm that's
where you get the greatest level of
divergence so that looks like changes in
atmospheric co2 where one of the drivers
are perhaps you will preconditions for
evolutionary diversification of c4 now
we've been working on how c4e vault and
beginning with work by r s Monson in the
genus loveria and continuing with many
other groups I picked up on this in the
last 15 years and we've come up with a
conceptual model for how you can build a
c4 plant and it basically follows as
I'll explain so from an ancestral c3
condition you have anatomical
preconditioning which we suspect might
be things such as close vein spacing
high genetic duplication and then we
propose that you have enlargement of
bundle sheath cells with more organelles
in the bundle sheath cells so that the
bundle sheath becomes physiologically
engaged and activated and then we have
mitochondria for some reason moving to
the inner bundle sheath wall and
together at this stage you get what we
call the proto Krantz condition because
you see you hints of crayons Anatomy
starting in these otherwise c3 plants
and then you get a key mutation where
you lose glycine decarboxylase
expression in the mesophyll and it's
only expressed in the bundle sheath
cells and associated with mitochondrial
enlargement and further elaboration of
musa filled a bundle sheath ratios you
get what's called a photo respiratory
co2 pump or a condition we call c to
photosynthesis and once this is
established you get up regulation of the
c4 cycle which then leads to full c4
photosynthesis so what I want to do now
is to show you some of the evidence we
have from two groups
heliotropium and Arachne ones that you
dicot one's a grass for this particular
model okay so before I begin I want to
just go over photorespiration a little
bit so some of this might make sense so
here's the photo respiratory pathway
possible glycolate made by the
oxygenation of ru vp is converted to
glycine in the proxy so this goes to the
mitochondria where an enzyme glycine
decarboxylase acts upon it releasing co2
and serine and the syrian is made back
to PGA and the co2 presumably is able to
escape from the cell ok now this co2
under high photo respiratory conditions
actually can be viewed as a resource and
if the plant can compartmentalize the
release of this GDC it can actually set
up a condition where this co2 can drive
improved photosynthesis and so r s
Monson proposed some years ago that you
get a specialization of the photo
respiratory pathway into two cell types
the meeza fill and bundle sheath and
this simply happens when you as GDC
expression in mesa fill mitochondria and
if you have enough mitochondria in the
bundle sheath which you can have in a
physiologically activated bundle sheath
then the photo respira Tori glycine
that's produced will have to flow from
the mesophyll which is much more
voluminous into the bundle sheath cells
where it can be acted upon by GDC to
release co2 and any chloroplast then
that are nearby can take this co2 and
assimilate it at a much higher
efficiency than what occur out in the
Me's a fill so you had in essence then
get a co2 concentrating mechanism form
simply by the relocalization of GDC so
we went into heliotropium section orthis
tackies which mike Froelich had
identified as having c3 c4 and c3 c4
intermediate species and taking lee
samples we
characterized their Anatomy we developed
a phylogeny which is shown here and we
looked at some of the physiological and
more recently some of the molecular
traits now the species we collected our
heliotropium Cal sekolah and ten elam
here at the base of the ortho stachys
clade we got heliotropium kerwin cin
procumbens here further up the clade we
got a thief or heliotropium text a.m.
and then these two intermediates convo
violaceum and Greg guys so you see a
sense of evolution phylogenetic
progression from a distal to a more or
from a basal to a more distal series of
branches with c4 ian acquired in the
more distal branches now here is the
anatomical progression that we see as we
move from a more basal to a more distal
position and this is typically see three
small bundle sheath cells without many
organelles in this heliotropium to
nellum you begin to see inflation of the
bundle sheath cells but not many
organelles heliotropium Kerensky I you
begin to see sort of a rounding out of
the bundle sheath cells into something
that sort of looking like yeah
preliminary first phase kranz anatomy
here's heliotropium procumbens with
pronounced but smallish bundle sheath
cells and here we are in the
intermediate heliotropium convo
violaceum and you can clearly see a
bundle sheath vascular patterning
becoming more pronounced and in the
intermediate heliotropium greggy I it
begins to look almost see for like with
big bundle sheath and then here are your
C fours now the data compiled from this
shows that the miza filled tissues drop
off in their percentage of the leaf
cross sections in the seahorse but not
so much in the C 3s or intermediate but
the big change is a buildup of bundle
sheath volume as you go along this this
phylogenetic gradient from the basal to
the more distal see threes and
then into the intermediate from the sea
force and this is seen also as a
reduction in mesa filled a bundle sheath
ratio vane doesn't density doesn't
change because the c3's have start out
with the high vein density that's
similar to the sea force which might be
a preconditioning trait now we look at
organelle levels in these things here we
see organelle per bundle sheath cell and
this is for the chloroplast this is for
the mitochondria and then this is
looking at the position of those
organelles the percent of organelles in
the inner bundle sheath going from the
basal species in that clade see three
ish guys into the intermediates and then
finally the seahorse and you don't
really see any c3 progression in
chloroplasts numbers the intermediates
have much higher chloroplast numbers the
c4s have variable this has few
chloroplast but they're gigantic the
mitochondria in the c3's you see
relatively low here but in the bundle
sheath of heliotropium Kerensky I we see
a significantly enhanced number of
mitochondria and then they get to be
quite high in the intermediates now the
positioning though shows a dramatic
change as we go up the FlyLo j'ni
towards the more distal branches you see
a progressive shift of chloroplast bages
positioning from the outer half to the
inner half such that by the time you're
in the intermediates most of the
chloroplasts are on the inside and the
mitochondria seem to show the same ship
so there's one c3 a second c3 and a 33
species as you're going from Basel to
the node that's sister to the
intermediate and ce4 branches we looked
at glycine decarboxylase localization
here's the c3 each of these brown spots
is where you have staining for glycine
decarboxylase in the mitochondria this
would reflect a mitochondria and you see
in here
trophy em tonnelle am the basal c3 its
scattered throughout the mesophyll
heliotropium Kerwin ski I which is a few
nodes more distal towards the c-4 clades
you see the glycine decarboxylase is
scattered throughout the Musa Phil but
you see this characteristic or this
interesting banding right around the
inner part of the bundle sheath any way
have patrol p.m. procumbens you see that
banding a little more strongly this is
physiologically ac3 species and when you
get into the intermediates you see no
decarboxylase expression out in the
mesophyll and it's all concentrated into
the bundle sheath especially along the
inner half of the cell lining the
vasculature and here's another view in
heliotropium Greg eaja c3 c4
intermediate and heliotropium text enum
shows a typical c4 pattern or GDC is
restricted to the bundle sheath now I
wanted to look at what's going on in car
winski I ac3 species physiologically and
here you see this vasculature which is
larger and more pronounced it's not huge
by c4 standards but it's big by c3
standards and here's the GDC stain and
you see there's a lot of GDC staining
along the inner part of the bundle
sheath cells here's the GDC out in the
mesophyll so we've looked at the
transmission electron micrograph at
what's going on and there's very few
mitochondria visible in this outer part
and instead they have lined up onto this
inner part here where they are
associated with a few chloroplast so
we've had in this sea three species that
sister to the intermediates a
polarization of mitochondrial
distribution now when we go to the full
c3 c4 intermediate heliotropium
confabulation a very fairly pronounced
bundle sheath enlargement very
pronounced GDC localization to the inner
part of the bundle sheath and when we
look at it at the TEM
see a very high number of mitochondria
here here here and this cap of
chloroplasts layering over them and this
is along this inner part of the bundle
sheet here's another view here and so
this then is the classic c3 c4
intermediate anatomy and physiology and
the idea is is that photo respiratory
glycine formed out lamesa phil has to
travel to these layer of mitochondria
here to be metabolized and release co2
which these chloroplasts can scarf up
with high efficiency and here's a
diagram of this mechanism where
photorespiration produces glycolate
which is made into glycine it comes into
these mitochondria because mitochondria
out the mesophyll have no GDC
mitochondria and the bundle sheath have
the GDC the co2 is released upon
metabolism of this glycine searing goes
back to complete the photo respiratory
cycle this co2 builds up to about three
times may be four times what otherwise
would be allowing these chloroplasts to
operate at high efficiency and the
effect of this on photosynthesis is
visible here c3 photosynthesis that
photosynthesis is a function of
intracellular co2 in the c3's you have a
high co2 compensation point a shallower
slope than you would in a C for a of
slowly saturating response and in the
sea to type this is based on c2 or this
is based on heliotropium you have a
reduction in co2 compensation point
slightly bigger initial slope and an
overall improved photosynthetic
performance at low co2 now I switched
into talking about C to photosynthesis
and this is a term that I coined to
refer
to try and come up with something that
physiologically describes this
metabolism separate from the term c3 c4
intermediacy which have been used
previously and it refers to the two
carbons in this glycine molecule that
shuttle co2 into this internal
compartment of the bundle sheath in a
similar manner as the four carbons in
malate that shuttles co2 into the bundle
sheath in c4 and the reason I came up
with this is because we were running
into confusion between what is a c3 c4
intermediate trait and what would be a
physiology that could exist in a much
wider range of plants than those that
are evolving towards see for now just
quickly another group the Naraka nay
we've been studying and this has c3 c3
c4 intermediates and ce4 species we
collected eight in the wilds of
Australia and sites like this here's the
intermediate species no F D minor
growing in a in a pot a rocky pot hole
that's been formed and here i just want
to show you bundle sheath and meeza fill
this is actually a specialized layer
called the me stumped sheath it's not
anatomically proper bundle sheath but to
vascular sheath layer and I want to look
at the mitochondria Purcell GDC /
mitochondria based on the number of gold
particles appearing in an immunoblot
stain and the GDC per cell area which is
GDC for mitochondria times the number of
mitochondria and I'm expressing this as
a function of co2 compensation point
where C 3 values are high right here and
ce4 values are the 0 ones right there
now in the bundle sheath we see the
number of mitochondria purcell going up
as we go to lower co2 compensation
points and then it comes down into the
sea for the GDC primito goes up as we go
to lower co2 compensation points and
correspondingly in the Me's of fill the
GDC levels per come down
in a progression and then the number of
gold particles per cell area which is a
function of my toes and so on you see
going up so you're getting a lot more
GDC in the bundle and the sheath cells
and a bit less out in the mesophyll so
you're seeing a similar pattern to what
we see in heliotropium in this grass
group of gradual enhancement of GDC in
the in the sheath cells while the
mesophyll progression goes down okay now
through the taxonomic or the
phylogenetic work and the isotope work
we've now identified a dozen independent
lineages where the c3 c4 intermediate
condition is is sister to the c-4
condition using this pattern of c2
photosynthesis but we've also identified
four clades with no evolutionary
relationship between c4 photosynthesis
and the expression of this c2
photosynthesis type metabolism now here
we have this again and what I want to
emphasize and this I got to thinking
about this in thinking about the fact
that this metabolism does not
necessarily have to be associated with
c4 evolution that it could operate as a
bona fide carbon concentrating mechanism
in its own right and a key thing about
this is no additional ETP expenditure is
required so you have a buildup of
glycine from high photorespiration and
by a strategic realization of GDC into
this one compartment where chloroplasts
can be enhanced you can affect co2
concentration without spending any extra
energy so we have then a passive co2
concentrating mechanism and it's kind of
interesting to think that in the case of
c-4 evolution the evolution of this
passive mechanism to scavenge photo
respired co2 laid the foundation or
built the bridge if you will to the
Seaport
edition by setting up this structural
musa filled a bundle sheath system and
upon this you could then layer on the
active see for metabolic cycle now this
pyramid diagram just shows the diversity
of photosynthetic CCMS inorganic pumping
of bicarbonate k MC for and now the c2
passive type but it got me to thinking
what might be going on in the sea threes
are they playing with photo respiratory
co2 to enhance rubisco efficiency and so
we decided to go and look for passive
CCM type of conditions in the c3 flora
and I'd like to begin with right now we
went and looked at rice mesophyll cells
as part of the c-4 engineering project
and one of the things that struck me
about these in this longitudinal section
here is the chloroplasts form this dense
layer around the periphery of the cell
here you see a nice view of that and the
mitochondria here here here here are all
positioned to the interior of this
chloroplast player which is quite thick
and where you have gaps between
chloroplast says right here you get
these extensions forming where the
chloroplasts blebs out to form a seal
between the two of them and block off
direct a flux routes out of the cell
here we see transverse sections and you
see there's a chloroplast in these lobed
protrusions of the miza fill cell here's
mitochondria to the inner part and
here's these extensions what we call
stromal extensions and here's some hi
mags of the extensions here you see an
extension sealing off a gap between two
chloroplasts here's a bunch of
mitochondria sandwich between the
chloroplast here's a case where the
chloroplast has actually been enveloped
by these chloroplast extensions there's
another case there and this got us to
thinking what could possibly be going on
here
we did an immuno gold blot for rubisco
and found that in these extensions or
stro meals you have rubisco present
here's a mitochondria that's blocked off
from the periphery of the cell by this
stromal extension and so we then redrew
the typical appearance of a c3 leaf to
create something like this layered on
the photo respiratory cycle here oxygen
is being taken up carboxyl 18 are you BP
to form fossil glycol II the glycine
then is metabolized by GDC and the rice
mitochondria co2 is released but it's
released into this internal space and
the only way out is through a
chloroplast or the stromal extension
which gives Rubisco a chance to capture
and refix this co2 and under for iphoto
respiratory conditions this surge of co2
produced could potentially enhance the
amount of co2 in the chloroplast and
improve rubisco efficiency so to test
this I formed a collaboration with Tammy
sage my faculty colleague Ace of cousins
Orion bushes my postdoc and in a paper
published in PC Andy a few years ago we
presented the results of our study now
what we wanted to do is to measure
directly the amount of fixation of photo
respired and respired co2 by
chloroplasts before it can leave the
cell to do this we used a pulse chase
system with carbon 13 where we first
loaded the leaves with carbon 12 and
then we all of a sudden switch them to
carbon 13 appear carbon 13 co2 source so
assimilation of carbon-13 measured by a
mass spec would give us photosynthesis
this way and then we'd be able to
measure the respiration signal by the
carbon 12 coming off and the carbon 12
that was refix tier would presumably be
coming from these mitochondria okay and
through a series of mathematical
calculations we were
able to estimate a number of things and
we did the measurements at 350 ppm and
30 degrees and in rice which has
chloroplasts coverage of the mesophyll
of 99 percent so 99 percent of the
mesophyll exposed to intercellular
spaces is covered by chloroplast we
measured the total reassimilate of
photos respired and riot respired co2
was about fifty one percent and
twenty-nine percent of that was coming
from co2 that was directly reassimilated
from mitochondria and we modeled then at
the increase in chloroplast co2 due to
this was 14 ppm and this led to an
11-percent enhancement of photosynthesis
now we repeated the measurements at 200
ppm which was the co2 level 20,000 years
ago here the total reassimilated was
estimated at fifty-nine percent of
respired and photo respired co2
intracellular reassimilate percent we
estimated that the co2 concentration
inside was enhanced by 16 parts per
million from this photo respired co2 and
that boosted see of photosynthesis by
thirty-three percent over what it
otherwise would have been and at these
low co2 conditions this level of
enhancement is actually starting to
become substantial we did the same for
wheat wheat also forms these stroh mules
here's a mitochondria and there's two
strong mules this is the view you would
get if you are looking at the wheat cell
standing face on and you can see the
high coverage of chloroplasts with only
a few gaps between them and so this
effectively forms a cage that will force
photo respired Co through through the
chloroplast as its diffusing from the
mitochondria to the outside of the leaf
and we just did these measurements at
350 ppm and we estimated that the co2
concentration and the chloroplast from
this photo respired co2 be enforced a
leaf through the chloroplast was 14 ppm
and you have an eleven percent
enhancement of photosynthesis as a
result so we call this reef fixation of
photo respired co2 and a question is how
widespread is this so if you go for
example into the c3 flora of the Mojave
Desert or say that subtropical
Australian woodland how many of these
species would have evolved a mechanism
to trap and refix this photo respired
co2 and thus compensate for the hot dry
conditions that you would have in these
kinds of environments and so one of the
things we want to do in coming years is
actually screened wild populations in
these environments prone to
photorespiration for this kind of
anatomy and it raises a paradox of the
modern biosphere which is the co2
concentration in the recent atmosphere
was quite low it got down to 180 ppm
20,000 years ago which in the tropics
would cause high levels of
photorespiration it averaged around 230
240 ppm throughout the Ice Age based on
ice-core records and so these conditions
would be strongly inhibitory because of
increased photorespiration you had c4
plants out there who would have provided
very strong competition yet despite all
of this ninety percent of the earth
plant species are c3 and most of the c3
plants occur in the tropics most of the
low-latitude biomes are dominated by c3
and c4 is actually rare and absent most
life forms such as trees and vines so
although c4's do well in certain
situations like grasslands they are not
the dominant vegetation of the warm
parts of the planet even in these very
low co2 times and so we're wondering
whether recycling a photo respired co2
is a way to offset or compensate for
these low co2 condition
now we've come up with the term pass of
co2 concentration to describe the sea to
photosynthetic system that can lead to
c4 or can exist independent of any c4
evolution and we've described some of
the criteria that would fit a passive
co2 concentration so co2 around some
rubisco is enhanced by strategic
placement of mitochondrial co2
assimilation or co2 emission no extra
energy is required hence the passive
aspect you need a resistive barrier to
slow the e flux of mitochondrial co2 the
Rubisco needs to have specifically
enhanced photo co2 and photosynthesis in
these regions where the photo respired
co2 is being released and if this system
is specifically selected for by natural
selection you could argue that it's a
bona fide adapt to feature in and of its
own right and of course if it enhances
carbon gain and fitness so I've
described see to photosynthesis but
we're arguing that this mechanism seen
in rice and its allies here is also a
passive co2 concentrating mechanism it's
not a huge impact but especially at low
co2 it's a significant impact that could
maybe enhance plant fitness enough to
offset the potential for say out
competition by c4 plants now when we
think about passive co2 systems we gotta
move and think beyond just
photorespiration but also respiratory
co2 and where you get thick respiratory
co2 tissue such as stems or fruits then
by putting a barrier in place you can
actually have a passive co2
concentrating mechanism so here we have
the stem of a birch and you have this
particular sclerotic layer ask lauren
coma layer in the outer part of the stem
here's the phloem parenchyma and the
chloroplasts and the Florham
grandma are autofluorescence showing
that they're fairly potentially
physiologically active respiratory co2
produced in this dam could diffuse out
but get held up by this chlorine coma
layer and potentially build up to a
point where photosynthesis in this
phloem layer and maybe down here in the
pit layer is enhanced so that Rubisco
can operate very efficiently insel a
janela you have a condition where a
thick cortical layer could provide a
resistive barrier and then you have
these lacunae that form and diffuse up
from below ground tissues bringing
respired co2 with them and be lining
these and by lining these below ground
for these lacunae from below ground with
chloroplasts the co2 that's coming up
from below ground from roots and tubers
rhizomes and even soil respired co2
could allow these chloroplasts to
operate with high levels of efficiency
so these may fit the criteria of a
passive CCM and it would be worth going
back and looking at many of these
species to see if these are specific
adaptations to improve the carbon
balance of these plants in geological
times of low co2 ok so if
that's it just a quick thanks to my
Thunder insert my various postdocs and
grad students who have worked with me on
the project Pascal Christian who we
collaborated with on a lot of the pile
of genetics and with that I'll take
questions to me do what to do which of
these is the traffic but that right says
they may we've looked at a half a dozen
crop species and they all do it to some
degrees some of them don't do it as much
as rice rice and wheat stand out and
having a very high chloroplasts number
so you get that complete chief around
the periphery that's expensive in terms
of nitrogen and other things and when
you go to a little nitrogen you see the
chloroplast becoming fewer in number and
they spread apart gaps formed between
them and then you see the reef fixation
potential going way down as CEO through
presumably leaks out much more readily
so there's a cost associated with it but
one of the things you see in the c3
plants is the floor plans tend to be
very thin and pushed up against the
periphery that indicating that evolution
is made for the small thin chloroplast
but a lot of them when you go to the
seahorse for example you don't have it
you have fewer chloroplasts and many of
them a much bigger because they don't
have photorespiration occurring out so
they don't have a solution airing
imperative to have to do
so yeah but most seem to have the
ability to do this if they have enough
nitrogen can build enough for Alexis
soggy so there's there's potentially a
lot of what's to making this decision
about temperature because temperature
affects the co2 and oxygen solubility do
you see with increasing temperature
among the scene three species the
greater propensity all to see to
concentrating mechanisms and all those
claims that i showed you are very high
temperature climate plants okay so if
you go to lower temperatures that you
see blessing you don't see any of us
yeah yeah so the c2 mechanism that we
see all those groups listed here
actually I think you see if I got a
picture of one of these guys growing in
its natural habitat there this is the
natural habitat for c2 this is the
mohave desert surface temperature here
during the growing season is 65 Celsius
the leaves are working around at here
belief temperature starts off at 20
degrees by the middle of the day is
approaching 50 this is its growing
season and it's supported by monsoon
rains that provides summer moisture so
at this condition especially the 300 or
280 ppm the pre-industrial co2 level
that would be really high
photorespiration so that's a big slug of
co2 which on the one hand you could just
let it go away or on the other hand by
strategically placing at GDC the not all
the sudden it's a great resource to
exploit yeah on that a little bit
c2 is a precursor or whatever the c4 why
AC to maintain do you see sec
environment segregation between Susan C
pours you might have expected everybody
that's in that kind of environment to
eventually evolve towards a c4 c2 is no
longer be damned yeah well everybody in
this kind of environment the sea fries
do do well but they may be doing well
because they're kind of sitting still
and it's this hot they use early morning
hours and close our stomachs and sleep
through the afternoon they take a siesta
before they may be operative offseason
during my winter or something so you do
see a lot of the c3 flora such as some
of these guys just shutting down on this
is hot I have seahorse exact same time
these grasses yeah Kristen course now
one of the things about these seed kids
is they tend to occur in these oddball
environments or they tend to occur as
weeds so for example the one that occurs
around here is a mallu go verticillata
which is called perfectly then it grows
on people's patios of lawns in July and
August it's it's a fugitive species so
it's sort of a escapes competition by
growing in these opportunistic but hot
side so if you have a black top in your
driveway and you don't pull your weeds
you're going to get carp and weed
growing in cornell in this kind of
otherwise moist climate but it's a very
hot microsite on that black [ __ ] so yeah
these values growing these very extreme
sanding rocky surfaces gypsum surfaces
where they grow where there's low
competition due to extreme or recent
disturbance so they're kind of escapists
the reason we think that is because once
c4d balls is the gas exchange diagram I
showed you it's superior and it just
exclude
guys out there they're not strong
competitors where's the seat boards are
Dave it was great fascinating the other
work that's been done in the elucidation
they had a comical evolution you didn't
mention most about Ted carboxyl aces vs
Rubisco and I wonder if you say word
about carboxylase where that fits into
the history whether there were other
avenues of evolution and carboxylase now
logs and also kind of lady to that could
to be some reason why carboxylase is a
challenging things i needed to evolve or
simply for a planet
well so carboxylase is the problem it
has in the existing c3 metabolism is
that it doesn't lead to net co2 fixation
so it is a gateway into the krebs cycle
but the carbon it produces oaa kreb
cycle intermediate and then may like to
run it through the kreb cycle you have
to get off that co2 fixed range kreb
cycle metabolism so you don't get net
fixation it's it actually serves as sort
of a gateway in and out of the kreb
cycle and in and out of fatty acid
metabolism and other things that need
the kreb cycle so to re-engineer pep
carboxylase to fit into an FC 0 2
fixation loop you may have to go and
screw up the kreb cycle metabolism which
would be a pretty big deal and
challenging for plants Pepsi ace itself
is quite ubiquitous appliances used in
many physiological functions and it's
there and in all of the land plants um
so using it is not a problem you just
need to upregulate it but you have to
couple it with something that leads to
net co2 fixation and the only
carboxylase in eukaryotes that we know
does that is is resistant now maybe if
we wanted to get into synthetic biology
and genetically engineer a completely
new photosynthetic thing with the full
bacterial ends line out the bacterial
per box lice and then put in some things
and create a new fixation schemin that's
been discussed but technologically we're
not
doesn't follow the evolutionary
speciation Mason projector from c3 to c4
and increasing importance
you follow that you see increasing
number of exit
well that's something that some we
actually want to go to hold all of these
intermediate guys we got most of these
in collection our various stages over
these guys so we have most of these in
collections but most of them only have a
few so you can't really get an
evolutionary progression because you
only got one or two immediate stages
okay most of them single tix on that
prc2 metabolism so there's not a lot of
very nation the different the exception
is an area here with mine but then this
one blood press that I've mentioned it
that we just did the pilot on they could
have up to 30 interviews and based on a
preliminary screen with a barian
material it looks like there's quite a
bit of variation in this intermediate
series of trait that's where you can go
in and look at when on this so-called
evolutionary progression you get step
changes gradual changes in the build-up
of plasma its modern or changes in mesa
fill chloroplasts which we've done for
claveria we look at where this change in
visa fill chloroplasts number occurs and
it seemed to occur progressively that's
just coming out plants on physiology so
yeah we can do that kind of thing but we
need to have very specious intermediate
groups do you have any monsters sorry
gentlemen
among all these phylogenetic studies
seen any evidence to the seaport breaks
down and falls back regress yeah there's
a few minor things electrolysis has
pretty good evidence for a reversion
there's probably a reversion in a
campaign in the Sussudio any group in
the which is in I forget the name of
this family now but there's good
evidence for reversion there in a group
called Sicilian which is but and there's
possibilities in the key know Gotye see
that you've had lost diversification of
the reconstituted c3 and then react was
a shin of support from that but is that
a real loss and react juez ition or is
that multiple evolutionary events and we
need much finer final genetic detail to
be able to address those hypotheses and
that's one of the priorities for coming
years is to go into these groups that
live to be fairly dynamic and see
whether they're dynamic or whether you
just got multiple c4 spinning off of
some predisposed to a serious
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu